from Olympic figure skating gold
medalist to 90s teen idols the cast of
Dancing with the Stars season 18
jam-packed with some of the hottest
celebs ET was with the contestants just
after the announcement and they would be
on one thing their partners should know
about them before they hit the dance
floor I'm Brooke Anderson with ET now I
like to enjoy myself when I'm working
hard I think that's the best way to to
get stuff done is to be able to enjoy it
otherwise you know you're gonna be
banging your head against the wall take
everything very literally so if he gives
me a direction to all life do that well
I meant partially do that I'll just like
I'm sorry this is what you said it's
what I'm gonna do a literal over in math
oriented so I'm in it to work really
hard and do the best that I can do it's
in the very blunt yeah I'm black and
white that's that's what I asked for I
asked the producers to give me the most
honest answer me it's the hardest thing
to find in Hollywood is an honest answer
sites that give me the most blunt person
but Real Housewives of Atlanta star NeNe
Leakes let her partner Tony Dovolani
knows something different than all the
rest that she's in it to lose it this is
a great way for me to get in shape I
want to lose 20 pounds I'm seeking Tony
get 20 pounds off of me I hate the gym
so this is something totally different
for me shake my hips he has so much more
from the new Dancing with the Stars cast
on tonight's show but tell me on Twitter
which star you're the most excited to
see when the show premieres on ABC
that's Monday March 17th I'm Brooke
Anderson with EP now
you